curious you have siblings you have
brothers i do i have one of each both
younger and they are not in the business
in fact i think they're quite uh
embarrassed by my uh by my occupation my
brother especially he's embarrassed by
you i think so i think he finds it uh
emasculating and and half the time i
can't really argue that
uh
he's someone who doesn't what does he do
if he thinks being an actress that's the
auto industry and and he's very
mechanical he's he's honestly i think a
genius he can fix anything in your house
he'll take apart your car and put it
back together over a weekend and so uh
uh it were extreme but i think for that
reason
he deems certain types of information
unworthy of his brain space the
information like his address
he doesn't know that
he doesn't know what's happening he's
one of those guys he's so talented in
one area yeah he called me a couple
months ago
he goes hey man what's up i said i could
hear the bar in the background i said
hey what's going on he said
how old am i
[Laughter]
i said you're 27. he said
god damn it
he had lost a bet at the bar on how old
he was
is he okay
i'm telling you he's an absolute genius
you know
it's not worth his brain space not worth
his brain space and he anything else odd
about him he says he's a character i
really want to get to know anything else
well he's great to gamble with yeah yeah
doesn't know his own age oh jeez that
he's uh we're a very close-knit family
he on his right arm
has a tattoo of the letter r for our
father's name was richard and i thought
that was very nice he said yeah i'm
gonna go back next week and get mom's
initial here our mother's name is louise
i said well you can't you can't do that
people are going to think you don't know
you're left from
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
our mother's first name is mary so he
had the m there so now he has mister on
his arms which is only
slightly less weird
now uh tell me a little bit about
yourself getting back to you you guys
get some downtime with the show you get
a few months off every now and then
would you like to what do you like to do
when you have some down time which i
travel a lot in fact i just i bought um
quite a bit of land up up north here in
california and um yeah i go up there and
kind of set things up it's quite a
reason quite a bit of land like what are
we talking here it's just over 300
acres 300 acres yeah
is there anything on it is there uh
there it well there's some vineyards on
it i felt like if you're gonna have that
kind of land it should function somehow
and i i'm not a horse person and i'm a
vegetarian so livestock was out of the
out of the question but i do like wine
uh
more than steak certainly and certainly
more than just being thrown off the
large animals could have just built a
liquor store on the property
that's not a bad idea because there's
there's really nothing mine is so hard
there's a small cab in there but i don't
i have nothing i don't even have a bed i
sleep on the floor in front of the
fireplace and i did buy uh uh i have a
tractor there wait you bought a tractor
but you didn't buy a bed yet yeah and i
honestly i remember mock your brother
that's what yeah
i need him to come up and show me
because i honestly don't know how to
turn the thing on i don't know where the
ignition is and the thing i bought a
tractor the tractor okay and i bought a
a giant trampoline
[Laughter]
you're gonna grow wine and just bounce
around
that is so northern california